[Music]
you know your fans love you they go
crazy for you especially the ladies out
there on Instagram you like taking those
shirtless selfies whoo those shots for
Earth aah
now they're just you know I'm gonna do
everyday I'm not I'm not working out so
that I'm the only person that sees it so
I guess you gotta you know you gotta
show off sometimes laughter Dave you got
it funny yeah I guess
[Music]
[Music]
you're working on now yeah I have an
album coming June 16th and then we're
gonna go into her and August so it's
gonna be great I feel a long time coming
up hey I mean absolutely and this is my
first independent album imma have no
record label now I'm by myself and I've
been writing producing all my songs so
this is the first album that I've from
the lyrics and the melody to the beats I
did it all so I'm really excited to show
everybody talk to me about tour man how
does it feel like perform that live for
all your fans yeah man it's amazing I
mean I've record music thinking of how
I'm gonna perform alive so I write my
songs based on thinking of that so being
on stage that's just like when I'm the
happiest my entire life so if can't wait
to get back on tour
[Music]